que tu as de grands yeux
Papou c'est pour mieux te
voir dis la grosse voix sous la couette
des nuits dédiées à la lecture et aux
activités culturelles cette année encore
les nuits de la lecture ont fait leur
grand retour organisé par le Centre
national du livre cet événement est
devenu un rendez-vous phare des
médiathèques du territoire pour nous
maintenant oui c'est devenu un
rendez-vous incontournable euh toute
l'équipe a plaisir à travailler sur ce
rendez-vous les publics sont là et nous
demande ce qu'on va faire et puis
répondre vraiment présent aux activités
qu'on leur propose le thème choisi pour
cette édition 2024 le corps clin d'œil
aux Jeux Olympiques il a donc fallu
choisir des œuvres où cette thématique
est abordée alors les amis c'est qui le
plus grand demande que le cochon
l'objectif de cet événement inculquer le
goût de lire aux petits et aux grands ça
me permet à les sensibiliser à la
lecture et les racontines ça permet ça
aide à ce que les enfants écoute parce
que nous on raconte pas forcément les
histoires de la même manière que que les
personnes qui le font et ben tous les
soirs avec ma petite fille on fait quoi
le soir on lit les histoires tu aimes
bien lire oui c'est important pour toi
oui en plus de la lecture pour honorer
la thématique du corps et du mouvement
un grand flash mob sur l'air d' School
Musical a clôturé la soirée une façon de
rendre l'événement à la fois culturel et
[Musique]
festif
that we
Ares and
we